hello VidCon is a weird time of the year
to make a video huh I'm overwhelmed so
I'm recording this a little bit early
meaning I'm recording it on Tuesday and
John your video just came out and so
here I am and I'm gonna do a question
Tuesday cuz I'm making a video on
Tuesday which never happens mostly
because doing anything more complicated
than question Tuesday would destroy me
but I'm fine I'm good so let's go on to
Twitter
hey it's question Tuesday the day that I
answer real questions from real
nerdfighters
I got I got partway through one that I
gave up opinions on gerrymandering
that's not really a question though you
didn't put a question mark at the end of
any think you should watch cede you'd be
great video about it
sports with John asks why aren't you
watching the USMNT I don't know what
that is really makes a great point that
the USMNT is almost certainly the United
States Mutant Ninja Turtles easy might
be adopting two kids tomorrow what
should she named the basiago and cheddar
Patrick wants to know if I have any
tricks for conquering insomnia I react
to stress with sleep I'm like a like one
of those sheep and I get scared and
falls over or those goats most of the
times I have suffered from insomnia it
has been because I drank caffeine so I
just don't do that I know that seems
very extreme to a lot of people but I
don't have that much of a problem
favorite kind of mmm peanut is you could
have a fictional person be a guest at
VidCon who would it be
I like this question Luna Lovegood how
Galadriel Huck Finn at Zed's art that's
a hard one I'm gonna die gonna have to
write a fanfic describe your feelings
about VidCon being this week I don't get
to think a lot about it it just happens
I form very few memories because they go
straight from one thing to the other and
I never have time to think about
anything but this one's going to be
particularly intense I think because we
are launching announcing three things we
are launching membership for the
internet creators deal you can go and
become a member of the guild if you are
a creator on the Internet the ICG is
basically just a thing that promotes the
interests of Internet creators we're
also announcing that there will be two
new vidcon's which is huge and kind of
shocking that it's finally happening
we're doing a VidCon in Melbourne
Australia and a VidCon in Amsterdam and
also I forgot about this because I can't
tell you about it we're announcing
another thing on Saturday which is
tomorrow when this video comes out and I
can't tell you about it yeah I'm sorry
about that but we're going to announce
it during the nerdfighter Meetup so you
have to be there or be somewhere else
slightly afterward because I'm sure
people will be tweeting about it it's
the kind of thing that you might wanna
pay attention to if you live near or in
Boston that's all I'm gonna say on a
scale of one to ten what's your favorite
color of the alphabet
have to say therapy how do you feel
about avocados that's an easy one also
the multiverse is the addition to that
which is a two-parter okay well I love
avocados I also love the multiverse
if the multiverse theory is true there's
there is a universe in which I am an
avocado what color are your sucks it's
the good color and also these these
colors as well and that's how we're
gonna end it thank you so much to
everybody who took my homework
assignment and did it there were so many
letters that I got on snapchat and
Facebook and Tumblr and Twitter things
like this remind me that we are still
doing thing with people and not just at
people and also it reminds me that we
are a part of how the world creates
itself and I'm very thankful to all the
people who took the time to write to
someone in their government about
something they were passionate about
John I would say that I would see you on
Tuesday but I'm going to see you before
then so I will see you very shortly good
video by the way this week